okay this one if you find the move
i want i want you to play uh i will
forever be
grateful i will
no pressure no pressure just 35 000
people watching because this is not an
easy move
you know abhishek i
and some comedians we had a group when
we had started the streaming
chess we had a group it was called uh
road to magnus
yeah and we never thought one day we
would be chilling with you and you'll be
on stream so
this is literally a dream come true like
literally yeah
i'm honored so for the first round we
are going to be playing
hand and brain where magnus will be the
brain of abhishek up menu
and with gujarati will be the brain of
me samarana
somewhere you shaved i shaved my
prepared for this
is not even interested in me man look at
it so
hand and brain right yeah it's handy
okay i know what you want to play
so i'll say pawn no no
no not that oh what how can i make a
mistake in the first move itself
because i know what you want to do on
the next move
yes come on please please yes i prepared
this
you sure yes okay please one pawn thank
you
this one is on you if something goes
wrong it's on you
do you know this opening i've i've seen
it before i'm just
okay so we're heading we want a
positional struggle right
i'm getting sleepy i'm gonna say pawn oh
oh oh oh
yeah it's a good move it's not a bad
move now i'm confused as well what
someone wants to do here
i i think it literally could be four
different moves that he wants here
um bishop okay let's go safe let's go
safe
why go save man just attack okay bishop
fine
i mean i can attack but we have to also
be take measured responses what is this
opening i have no idea
it's a romantic opening this has been
known since
practically since chess was invented oh
wow
[ __ ] it oh yes yes i know
i i love it listen to me you have to
place the crowd
with it i beg you think
think beautiful think romantic do not
think materially
man i know what you want come on let's
go for it
are you two dating king yes
he is literally prepared for the stream
yes yes
okay i mean this is collusion to some
extent i would say
but um they're giving us stuff so i'm
gonna say pawn
this is collusion yeah i mean you're
you you are uh clearly hinting so oh
yeah okay
okay queen nice
this could be ugly could be this is not
what i
i woke up for
[Laughter]
let's just say that okay fun
you should be able to do it okay
now we defend should i trust somebody
yes please
i mean you know you shouldn't
[Music]
okay queen queen bro never move the same
piece twice in the opening with it
yeah you've already moved the queen
i love this opening you know i love this
aggressive opening
yes very safe
so um night okay i think this is how
it's done
yeah if you had played 93 i would have
left the stream
yeah i have a couple of objects i
predict that in about
five moves we're just gonna be piece up
with
what
oh there is a very nice move but will
you find it
i will find it bro i am 1570. um okay
we go all in right yeah we spare nothing
okay let's go bishop
okay we shall see only one bishop can
know that's
in my favor yes i can see five legal
notes right
that's way too much yeah but only uh
okay few makes sense
guys i think i have found it yeah i
found it
now i'm proud now i'm proud
what what why why is this move played
can you
explain uh you'll find out you'll find
out basically
they put the bishop on a light square so
we should
in general put the king on the dark
square if we can oh
nice thank you abhishek why this is what
i wanted you to oh man
you're doing well you're doing very well
don't worry okay
i'm gonna say uh i'm gonna say nights
night oh wow really
oh i know what you want to do okay um
somewhere
yeah you got this yeah i got this uh
bishop bishop yes
this is not gonna be close no he'll find
it i know i
know because one bishop can't even move
yeah yeah
nice nice um queen okay this one
if you find the move i want i want you
to play
uh i will forever be grateful i will
no pressure no pressure just 35 000
people watching
because this is not an easy man take
your time take your time
take seven minutes he is
so what i'm gonna tell you is that there
is one move that's
okay and there is one move that's that's
pretty good
the rest the rest are really really
really really really really bad
once again no pressure sorry about
all that we got to play at some point oh
yeah
okay oh i know what magnum magnus you
wanted a5 right
yeah good game so yeah indeed good game
so far
i thought after the opening will win
easily but the defense
kicked in not sure where but i'm
thinking
no just play what you want to play okay
okay it's fine it's fine
are we up material no queen we are not
that we are peace down
oh no we only have attack you play the
king's gambit dude yeah
you're never gonna be off material
you're like museo can be
things gambit and now play this is a
problem oh
night night night night
yes that's what pawn on d4 somewhere
that would have stopped knight e5 oh
it's fine it's fine
okay queen hmm
okay okay bishop you trust yeah magnus
yeah i'm trusting i'm trusting i've got
i've gotten
such a good response so far okay
[Laughter]
come on with it we don't have time um
and we don't have
also but it's fine um okay okay okay
okay we will do one great move yeah fast
fast secure skinking king
king yeah oh yeah okay i mean
get out of all the problems there is a
knight yes
you don't get to be surprised that my
queen's i'm getting pretty surprised at
yours
[Laughter]
look really okay queen by the way the
chat is not working
youtube crashed
rook what is chat saying yeah charities
thank you so much
[Laughter]
what we lost you played queen g3 you
should have played queenie two
i didn't know i didn't see i you you are
distracted
you last move you said queenie i was
going for this background
a lot background somewhere back ranked
mate
the most oldest like simplest made
possible
let's change the topic
[Music]
you